well peterson so far in his young career
you see his toyota numbers this season
has found success here at city field
four and one with a 3.98 era
and the slider catches the inside corner
and topping as a strikeout victim to
start the night
10th start of the year for austin gomber
and the walks
those 22 walks that that's a big number
but most of those very very early in the
season
well that's a nasty slider to strike out
lindeur
two outs
three one
this ball is pretty well hit to right
charlie going back charlie will make the
catch
what a wonderful grab he gets to stare
down james mccann the left-handed
hitting ryan mcmahon
this ball hammered to deep right way
back take a good look you won't see it
for long one nothing colorado as ryan
mcmahon got a hanging slider and spoked
it out of the ballpark for his 12th big
fly of the year mcmahon's at such a good
place right now
[Music]
he's been taking fastball shooting him
opposite field
and when you get a slider like that
you have to do some damage
boom
josh fuentes the third baseman coming up
and this one to a wide open space mccann
with a great diving stop and he hits
peterson
james mccann
playing his first professional game at
first base ranged almost halfway to
second made a diving stop and from his
knees
throws out fuentes who just happens to
be nolan arenado's cousin
and mccann is getting a standing ovation
a little bit of athleticism here oh
right your screen there he comes
very nice
how about that he knows how to throw
from his knees look at his hat i know it
folded over because he hit the ground
two outs the rockies catcher diaz comes
up still looking for his first home run
of the year
this ball lifted to deep left field stay
fair
and this one's gone diaz we're just
talking about looking for that first bob
two-nothing colorado
good for elias man he has grinded at the
plate this year and spilly we've talked
a little bit about it off here the bat
at bats have looked better another
slider
the subaru super mo
rocky's hitters came out early to city
feel around 2 o'clock they
brought out the pitching machine they
faced curve balls
fastballs mcmahon loved it gives charlie
a little hug garrett hamson the center
fielder for the rockies two-nothing they
lead it over the mets
next pitch hit in the air
center field giving ground vargas back
to the wall reaches out and he cannot
make the play he crashes into the wall
fuentes is around third he comes to the
plate and scores and the rockies lead
three to nothing well the mets lost
brandon nemo to a finger injury they
lost albert almora when he crashed into
the fence they lost kevin pillar when he
got hit in the face and now janeshui
fargus the next man on the depth chart
hoping that he's not the next guy on the
injured lift he did at the beginning
miss uh this uh had a wrong track to the
ball and that's the difference of him
not getting there here's the collision
yeah it's kind of
yeah
but it still hurts yeah all the weight
of his body crashed into that wall and
shoulder at the same time
[Applause]
heads up by maven to come over and pick
that ball up otherwise hampson who has
great speed might have had an inside the
park home run here's khalil lee
oh two pitch swing and a miss by lee and
he is strikeout victim number five on
three pitches for austin gomber
this is going to be
alfredo tovar
pitch is hit towards left coming on
tapia he's got it
boy austin gomber
67 pitches and he's done with six
innings and now face james mccann who's
been up twice and flight out to right
both times
mccann drives one out to left field
tapia going back warning track at the
wall it's out of here
james mccann number three hitter in
first baseman hits a home run
his second home run as a met
[Applause]
and thus the mets are on the board for
the first time it's three to one
colorado
have yourself a night james hit a ball
in the noses first time up
fall down in the strike zone
[Applause]
when he made contact i thought it would
run up with the label a little bit but
he's so strong
it got enough of that barrel
mets have been waiting for mccann to
break out offensively all you have to do
is move him to an offensive position
austin gomber
he gets tomas neato swing and a miss
came back with the changeup and strikes
out neato
that is number seven on the night for
austin here comes the 2-2
swing and a missed season high eight
strikeouts for austin gomber brandon
drury is going to bat for khalil lee
leading off in the bottom of the night
and drury gets a hold of one to left
field back to where the corner goes
topia back near the wall it's out of
here
brandon drury with his first home run as
a new york mets and he cuts the rockies
lead to a single run it's down three to
two
pinch hit home run for brandon drury and
now the mets have life of the ninth
watch the backswing pulp good contact
ouch
[Applause]
[Music]
well he connected on this one
he lost his grip
that's why he clobbered himself
[Applause]
his first home run since 2019 when he
hit 15 for the blue jays the mets are
down to their final out big night for
mccann this could be quite a story
couldn't it one two
he's got him and the rockies win he went
with gasoline at 98.
what a performance by austin gomber and
the rockies have won four straight
just their third road win of the year
and for carlos estevez who had struggled
early he struggled in spring training an
enormous save his second of the year the
14th of his career